Two women have now come forward to corroborate
the latest rape allegations against President
Donald Trump.
I told you a few days ago that ie Jean Carol
went public with the allegation that Donald
Trump raped her in the 1990s in the New York
City department store.
The right, the Trumpists immediately called
her crazy wacky, not trustworthy.
Uh, Trump claimed he doesn't know her and
that anyway, she's not his type, which is
code four.
She's not attractive enough for me to rape
her.
Well, two women have now confirmed that at
the time of the alleged rape and Carol told
them about it, they each had different advice
for EEG and Carol at the time and at the time
Adrian Carol specifically said, Donald Trump
is the person who raped me.
The two women are Carol Martin and Lisa Bernbach.
Carol Martin admits that at the time she suggested
to Eg and Carol that she not talk about the
incident publicly because Donald Trump is
simply too powerful and it would be re risky
to her to go public.
Bernbach says that at the time she told and
Carol go directly to the police with what
happened to you.
As we know Eg and Carol didn't do any of those
things.
Ultimately blaming herself and ending up telling
no one publicly for years and years.
So listen first they said no one would corroborate
the story.
Now there are two people corroborating it.
Of course they will now attack these women
as untrustworthy.
They will say, oh sure.
Now they're saying EEG and Carol told them.
I told them at the time, but where were they
back then?
Which is insane.
It would it be logical for someone who is
told in confidence about a sexual assault
and that person decides they don't want to
go public to go around telling people about
it.
That would be ridiculous.
But that is what they are going to do.
They're going to attack these two women and
what you need to understand is that there
is nothing unique about these allegations
against Donald Trump.
Trump's own ex wife testified that Donald
Trump raped her during their marriage.
The Republican Party just doesn't care about
this.
That's what you have to understand.
It's easy to say, well, they simply don't
believe this particular allegation.
Well, Trump's grabbing by the pussy tape came
out and they elected him.
President Roy Moore was accused of serial
sex assault, including against underage girls,
and he got 48.3% of the vote in the Alabama
Senate race.
He almost got elected despite those allegations
and now he's running again and why wouldn't
he?
He almost one last time.
So it's not that they literally don't believe
it.
Maybe some of them don't.
It's that they don't care either way.
So why not simply say they don't believe it?
Either way they're voting for the person.
We'll see what else comes with this.
We need to try, I mean, listen, there've been
so many of these allegations and we talk about
it.
Our video about Trump's child rape accuser
I think has hundreds of thousands of views
if not even more than that.
I haven't looked for awhile, but it's clearly
of interest to a contingent of the electorate.
But corporate media is hesitating to cover
this stuff in detail.
Um, and uh, we need to see if any of these
stories will actually stick in some way, shape
or form.
Let me know what you think.
Let me know what coverage should be of these
accusers.